municipal violations there the small
everyday ways of breaking the law like
speeding or trespassing or and this is
true failing to vaccinate your ferret
that is actually against the law so
sorry ferret Jenny McCarthy you're just
gonna have to get it done the point is
we have all committed municipal
violations and if you've never gotten a
ticket for one all I can say is
congratulations on not getting caught
now for most people tickets are just
annoying and we grin and bear them or as
in the case of this young woman throw a
passive-aggressive tantrum citation is
for I nobody likes me neither
yes you're right but I take something
out having your headlights on take care
of this ticket on before the third you
just know that woman behaves that way in
every situation yeah I totally get it
it's a funeral Mindy was a person now
she's gonna be like eaten by words just
to put her in the ground so I can get to
SoulCycle I'm like oh now she's probably
not thought about that ticket until I'm
guessing round about now when she's
getting a lot of text messages from
friends saying amber you're totally on
HBO right now shouting at a cop
but but if you don't have enough money
to pay a fine immediately tickets can
wreck your life let me introduce you to
a woman named Harriet Cleveland she had
some low-level traffic tickets but
because she couldn't pay them
straightaway she accumulated all kinds
of other fees and additional tickets
which despite her best efforts she was
unable to pay off and then one morning
this happened I had my grandbaby with me
and I was sitting up giving him
breakfast that morning and I heard a
knock on the door and I sent a police
officer at my door and in the back of my
mind it wasn't for me because I didn't
figure they'd come get you for tickets I
was escorted to jail and if you're
thinking how the is it possible for
a grandmother to go to jail for traffic
tickets or that is what this story is
about because let's start at the
beginning most tickets come with a fine
and if you've ever lived paycheck to
paycheck you know that can be difficult
for example in DeKalb County Alabama a
speeding ticket is two hundred and fifty
five dollars and fifty cents if you earn
minimum wage there 725 an hour it would
take you more than thirty five hours of
work to pay that off which seems harsh
because the only justifiable way you
should lose an entire week of your life
due to speeding is if you hit 88 miles
an hour and go back in time and
sometimes government's will take a
reasonable base vine and turn it into
something that people may not be able to
afford as they've done in California the
actual fine for running a stop sign is
$35 but by the time the state tax on 10
different surcharges and fees the amount
you owe jumps is $238 now just to put
that in perspective I went on eBay this
morning and 238 dollars is the current
asking price for this glorious unicorn
with wheels on its hooves so that's
right if you live in California and run
a stop sign you can either pay your
ticket or own a unicorn
now now courts know that not everyone
can pay fine straightaway which is why
some allow a payment plan unfortunately
that can turn out to be even more
expensive in Illinois the state ads
aren't 30 percent if you fall behind in
your payments in New Orleans it cost you
a hundred bucks just to sign up for a
payment plan yes your payment plan
begins with a payment plan payment it's
not your probation officer is MC escher
just just go pay the clerk at the top of
that endless staircase you'll be fine
and this situation is widespread at
least 44 states charge people a fee to
be on probation and many municipalities
use these charges as a way to fund local
services without raising taxes and if
that rings a bell at all to you it may
be because of Ferguson Missouri
because when the recent Department of
Justice report uncovered institutional
racism it found one of the ways it
manifested was in the use of fines as a
cash machine the report says officers
competed to see who could write the most
tickets it also concludes police
officers promotions depended on citation
revenue then there's the story of a
police commander who one day bragged to
his superiors about seeing a steady
stream of people 10 to 15 deep waiting
in line for hours to pay traffic fines
he wrote the court clerk girls have been
swamped and the city manager responded
great work ok
setting aside the fact that he used the
phrase court clerk girls
that's situation if ridiculous the only
people who should be that excited about
people waiting in line to hand over way
too much money are Apple executives
that's the only time and if you couldn't
pay immediately in Ferguson they could
bleed you dry
listen to just one example in 2007 one
woman received two parking tickets that
together totaled 152 dollars to date she
has paid 550 dollars in fines and fees
to the city of Ferguson yet today she
still inexplicably owes Ferguson five
hundred and forty-one dollars that's
more than a thousand dollars for a
hundred and fifty dollars in tickets
even people stocking a hotel minibars
are thinking that markup seems
just settle down and using funds to fund
government was not happening just in
Ferguson as a recent study of the
surrounding area showed according to
court records eight towns rely on court
fines and fees for more than 30 percent
of their revenue Calverton Park is at
the 66% level
sixty-six percent went that much of your
budget comes from fines you're actually
rooting for people to break the law
listen everyone we're gonna have to
close the library unless someone
urinates up that wall and the rest of us
start driving like maniacs so put the
pedal to the metal let's do it for the
kids and the problem is in these
situations the poor get hurt the worst
in many states failure to pay a fine on
time can even result in having your
driving license suspended in fact this
is such a common practice the minke
Orange County Florida they even made an
event out of it
The Grinch himself showed up in Orange
County with a bag full of licenses
belonging to drivers who've been more
naughty than night we're sending the
message that if you're gonna come out
here and you're gonna drive in a manner
that affects somebody else's life or
safety that we're going to impact your
life okay okay first of all
you do know the Grinch is the bad guy in
that story right it's not about a brave
green crime fighter who saves Whoville
from a guy driving his sleigh ten miles
over the speed limit but but secondly
the Grinch's argument that this was all
about affecting people's lives and
safety was somewhat undercut a little
later in the same report many of these
licenses were suspended simply because
the drivers didn't pay a traffic ticket
exactly those licenses weren't all taken
from reckless drivers the odds are they
were mostly taken from insolvent drivers
in 2012 in Florida a staggering 88% of
all license suspensions were due to
failure to comply with summons or fines
which is insane it also leaves only 12%
for Florida's other most common
violations accidentally taking your golf
cart on the freeway feeding meth to an
alligator feeding an alligator to a meth
dealer and being an alligator meth
dealer Florida if you lose your license
it can affect everything
most Americans drive to work and if you
can't do that you've got a problem in
New Jersey a survey of low-income
drivers who'd had their license
suspended found that 64% had lost their
jobs as a result which doesn't help
anyone you need them to pay their fine
but you're taking away their means of
paying it that's the most self-defeating
idea since gay conversion camp hey don't
worry boys will fix you it's swimming in
the morning wrestling in the afternoon
and in the evening general horseplay in
the woods you'll be fine you'll be fine
chaps
what let's recap if you get a ticket and
you can't pay it you may get additional
fines lose your license and eventually
your job and if you're thinking is there
any way this whole situation can be made
even worse relax there is because now
private companies have somehow managed
to insert themselves private probation
companies across the u.s. supervise
people who are on probation for minor
offenses collect all of their
outstanding debts and fines and court
costs and they won't charge the courts a
penny instead probationers pay them fees
in exchange for their services
yes companies like judicial correction
services and Sentinel offender services
offer to supervise probationers and
collect fees on the courts behalf at no
cost
but even market themselves with ads like
this one for JCS trumpeting the millions
of dollars they collect for
municipalities the problem is that money
is a lot like Wendy's chili it's
fantastic to have just as long as you
don't think about where it came from
because it can come from people like
Hayley Woods August of last year I got a
no seatbelt ticket how much was that
ticket for it was the ticket struttin
was 25 dollars in court cost was 16
which was 41 and then I had I didn't
have the money to pay so they put me on
JC s probation that's right Hayley was
handed over to JC s probation because
she couldn't pay a $41 ticket they put
her on a payment plan with a monthly fee
of $35 the problem for Hayley was any
money she sent in was applied to her JC
s fees first and not her $41 ticket
which put her in a hamster wheel of hell
this one right here shows I've had
another $10 shows that the fees went
down but the finest till $41
have the money to pay for the ticket and
I couldn't afford the rest of the fees
and he said that that wasn't his problem
that I could just put that $41 towards
the probation and then I got another one
that shows I paid forty one dollars even
and the fund has not been touched not
one time all the money I've paid Wow so
if you have money the state slogan is
click it or ticket but if you don't it
should really be buckle yourself or go
yourself and in case they just want
some power not angry enough by now just
remember how this system works if you do
have money you didn't think it was
possible to dislike her anymore digit
amber you're back on TV this is sick and
and it's not just that these private
probation companies can take your money
their recommendations to the court can
ultimately send you to jail take the
case of Tom Barrett he's a veteran who
stole a $2 can of beer which he knows he
should not have done and when he
couldn't pay his fine he was referred to
Sentinel offender services now in
addition to all their other fees they
gave Tom a court-ordered leg monitor for
which they charged him three hundred and
sixty dollars a month twelve dollars a
day to keep up on his payments he had to
stop selling his own plasma and where do
you think this story ended I ended up
having to walk everywhere because I
didn't I could afford bus fare um I went
hungry because I could afford food it
was $12 a day and there was no way I
could make $12 a day so it's always
falling behind so I ended up getting
locked up three times over stealing this
can of beer locked up three times over
stealing one can of beer that is not
justice that's the plot of a southern
lane miserable
I dreamed a dream I stole a course and
then some put me in jail the
crazy thing is the main reason
municipalities signed contracts with
these companies is to save money and yet
this whole system doesn't even make
sense on a financial basis because as
Tom Barrett's lawyer explains locking
him up was expensive I know the jailing
called $50 a day and I think he would
probably in jail for at least 60 days or
30 days so probably over $3,500 so just
think about that a $2 can of beer caused
a two hundred and seventy dollar fine
which the city spent over three thousand
dollars to try and enforce but you know
what it's like they say you got to spend
money to make money to be able to afford
to jail people to lose money that's the
system right and all this brings us
right back to where we began with
Harriet Cleveland because her story
touches on pretty much everything we've
seen so far
how did Harriet wind up in jail well she
struggled to pay traffic tickets had her
license suspended had to keep driving or
she'd lose her job was then caught
driving without a license ticketed again
and then had her fines handed over to
the good people at JCS and I'll let her
pick up the story from there I just
really lost a whole lot of money
painting him they didn't go onto my
phone I lost my car trying to pay them I
did a title loan on my car and lost that
and trying to pay my utility bills you
know and they getting shut off here in
the air to pay my fine but I can't
afford it and like I said just hurt it I
don't even have that tape but I had to
take something see it got to the point I
just got tired and I couldn't take
anything anymore I paid him $2,000 one
time when I got me income tax anything
that was in February and in March I just
have anything else to give him that is
awful now the Southern Poverty Law
Center eventually managed to get her out
of jail after ten days arguing that
she'd been sent to what was effectively
a
debtors prison something that was
supposed to have been outlawed in
America in the 1830s but the truth is
whether through private probation or
just the state's many people have been
caught in the same cycle as all the
people that we've seen and let's be
clear no one is saying that people who
break the law should not be punished
this isn't about being soft on crime
listen to Tom Barrett self-proclaimed
conservative Republican lawyer if
someone violates the rules of society
they need to be punished but the
punishment need to have some if it's
going to be based on a fine it had to be
based on the person's ability to pay
they don't have the ability to pay they
can pick up trash on the street so they
can have some community service I think
pretty much everyone would agree with
that not only should municipalities not
be balancing their books on the backs of
some of their most vulnerable citizens
but we cannot have a system where
committing a minor violation can end up
putting you in and I'm going to use a
legal term of art here the barrel we
can't have that and it might be time
that we all stood up and said so I'm a
hostess I'm a barista I'm a cashier I'm
a utility inspector I am a hairstylist
I'm a janitor and cook we are all
Americans and we have the right to life
liberty in the pursuit of happiness but
sometimes in that pursuit we also need
the right to up once in a while
without a completely destroying our
lives all the time actually I have
gotten the speeding ticket yeah I mean I
publicly urinated maybe once or twice
public drunkenness
of course your boyfriend's drunk in
public baby got tickets to spend on the
floor I got a ticket for petty loitering
I got arrested for smoking weed at a
concert and then I met GZA from wu-tang
and he gave me a VIP pass back into the
thank you digit yes thank you Jesus and
when we truly made a mistake we're all
willing to pay a price but that price
should be reasonable and private company
should not be profiting from someone's
inability to pay once I'm I've put a
popsicle on my friend's ass okay that
doesn't really apply to what we're
talking about here but thanks for
sharing the point is this is everyone's
problem young old black white it's not
about race it's definitely about race
race definitely plays listen to it for
sure I highly doubt that loitering thing
I got would have happened to me if I was
forget about me being white if I was
like a couple of shades lighter okay
you're right it's absolutely about race
as well but it's also about basic
fairness and it has to stop because
people cannot end up enough barrel for
the little stuff we all do so it's time
for us all to come together and say as
one shut down the shut down shut down
this I said shut down barrel shut down
please
yes shut down the barrel shut it down
you